NEED TO GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
BOWMAN.DED
SKATING UP ICE, A PASS OVER TO
THEY ARE RIGHT BACK AT IT.
JOHNNY GAUDREAU HEADING TO THE
NET,
NOAH HANIFIN, FIRST ON THE SCORD
SO PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR
THERE AS HE WAS ON THAT
JUST LIKE T MIKAEL
BACKLUND SETS UP MATTHEW
TKACHUK, AND THE WAY HE
VERY FUNNY.
>> Harnarayan: IT UP,
RASMUS ANDERSSON SHOOTS AND
SCORES!
IT'S 3-ZIP GUY THAT STEPS UP AND
AROUND.
HE SAID HE ANTICIPATED A
DIFFERENT TEAM.
HERE'S ANOTHER  FROM VLADAR,
THE PAD ST CANUCKS STILL PRESSI.
GOOD CYCLING OF THE PUCK THIS
AS THEY
DOWN HE KEEPS THE MINDSET OF
TO THE
OTHER SIDE AS RASMUS ANDERSSON
STEPS UP, LUCIC A SHOT
WHO'S EXCITED, AND HE MAKES A
BEAUTIFUL MOVE.
OVER TO
TRYING TO GET A STEP ON PETAN,
STOLEN BY HUNT.
VANCOUVER'S HAD JUST ONE
MANGIAPANE PARKED
NOW JOHNNY GAUDREAU, FINDS
TKACHUK.
TKACHU
[ Cheers and Applause ]
JOHNNY GAUDREAU WITH HIS 28TH OF
THE SEASON.
IT'S A POWER PLAY
HIS POST PLAY A LITTLE BIT.
HE GETS TURNED
[ Cheers and Applause ]
SHOT
CENTREMAN, AND THERE GOOD
GOAL FOR MATTHEW HIGHMORE.
HE DESERVES IT
NET!
[ Horn ]
BROCK BOESER OFF THE SKATE OF B
AND HE'S ABLE HORVAT'S
IN WITH PODKOLZIN.
PODKOLZIN